so john lester gets the fifth start of
his season as a member of the cardinals
number 444 in his career 445th career
appearance
and there's a strikeout to start our
afternoon here at bush well that's
lester throwing to a corner and that's
uh an umpire not taking it away from him
and i'm all for it as we mentioned
there's a ground ball left side could be
two the turn
double play
and on the mount for the tigers you have
tarik skubal big lefty overpowering
fastball
that is hammered deep left at the
[Applause]
paul goldschmidt
number 20 this year
rbi number 900 of his career one to
nothing st louis he was in our open we
said paul goldschmidt has been hot in
august needs to spark the team so here's
some spark for you 94 he turned on it
that was a no doubter that ball carried
over the bullpen
wave and a miss down goes carlson
already two strikeouts for school waits
out another 2-2
and here it is
scuba strikes out the side but does give
up the paul goldschmidt home run both
teams lost so four and a half out
and that already is strikeout number
four for scooble
had him out front sold it well 85 mile
an hour change up
he puts him away
strikes out the side for the second
straight inning jonathan scope against
leicester he doesn't give in to you
scope drills one by a diving arenado
into the left field corner it's fielded
by dylan carlson
and jonathan scope trots his way in for
a one-out double
well scored the cardinals 14-4 diving
stop arenado oh what a play nolan
oronato to his left
as he robs
robbie grossman
i'm not sure if de young would have been
able to knock this down on the infield
but nolan says why not just do it this
way and make sure he doesn't score and
let's get it out really good range by r
[Applause]
once he gets the baseball dan you almost
start calling him out already goldsmith
at 33 years old long home run his first
time up as goldie lifts it down the
right field line and that is gone
it's all paul goldschmidt today
goldie too
detroit nothing
let's make a mental note to talk about
him in our open tomorrow as well
as he hits this one the other way pulled
one
but he's not a one-trick pony he's got
power the other way you talked about
cabrera's power the other way
that ball really carried to right field
good start for goldie today scuba's got
seven punch-outs on the day anyway one
of them looking and that's the opposing
pitcher de young's down swinging for the
second time today make it eight for
scooble and then struck out 17 while
walking only two
strikes out sosa
and that's how the cardinals get mowed
down here
you know that three times through a
lineup analytics will tell you that
could mean trouble
derrick hill drives into a right center
field gap
that'll feed all the way to the wall
good speed for hill will he dig for
three
yes no now he's gonna retreat and that
was a wise move a two-out double for
derek hill jonathan scope batting
here's the 1-0
scope the other way and that's down a
base hit for jonathan scope derek hill
is going to push it all the way home in
for the head first slide and the tigers
are on the board thanks to the jonathan
scope rbi single it's a two-out rally
for detroit here in the fifth here's
that cutter on the back outside part of
the plate jonathan scope looking to go
that way
and he drives in
derrick hill for the tigers first run
he gets zach short to start
wow oh my short hop spin out what a play
nolan oronato he's been busy today down
at the hot corner wow what a play and
watch him show off the balls hit sharply
juan hop he catches it there's the spin
that was his way of just kind of giving
with the ball
going with the hop
reorienting himself and as we say the
throw is always right on the money
jonathan scope leads off the tigers
eighth and what a day he's had he walked
in the first he doubled in the third and
drove in a run with a single in the
fifth
the 1-0
that's a fair ball down the left field
line all the way into the corner
scope will dig for his second double of
the day he's got it it leads off the
eighth scope has done a good job of
getting pitches in the strike zone that
he can handle here's a breaking ball
that's right over the middle of the
plate
and scope didn't miss it
he's had some really good swings today
one two again swing and a miss and a big
strikeout for gallegos
there's the slider working
the next by giovanni gallegos
is a fly ball lifted out to left
battling the sun dylan carlson
with the catch runner doesn't tag out
number two
fly ball
right center
vader there leadoff double
scope left stranded
two outs for miguel cabrera
down the right field line and deep and
that ball is up against the wall
played by carlson quickly gets it in
cabrera's got himself a two out double
he gets a fastball up and out of the
plate and
puts a really good swing on this pitch
fell for a second that ball had a chance
to get out me too down the right field
line i think a lot of people felt that
there at busch stadium instead cabrera
settles for the double and harold castro
comes in in the number nine spot in the
order to try and drive him home
the 1-2
base hit up the middle for harold castro
cabrera is going to be waved home here's
the throw from bader not in time and the
tigers have tied it at two
a masterful job by the tigers here in
the ninth to tie it up with
three pinch hitters in a row
what a good at bat here by harold castle
fastball on the inner half does an
excellent job of pulling the hands
inside and getting inside that baseball
using the middle of the field
lies neutral he could end it here the
2-1 pitch
newt barr hits it right side base hit
the cardinals win it
the rookie comes through
nude bar
first ever walk-up hit